- Welcome back.
With a diverse sound that
combines blues, rock,
Americana, and folk, our next
guests are among the biggest
up and comers in country music.
In the past year, they've
toured the country
and made their Grand Ole Opry debut,
and right now they're about to make
their network television debut.
Now performing "Annabel"
off their new album
"Fortune Favors the Bold,"
give it up for 49 Winchester.
(Kelly claps)
(audience cheers and applauds)
♪ Ah, ah ♪
(upbeat country music)
♪ Well, I can never think correctly ♪
♪ And you can never show your heart ♪
♪ I was set in my ways
and you wanted to change ♪
♪ And we both fell apart ♪
♪ You wanted a man to marry ♪
♪ And I could never get past my sin ♪
♪ It was all just so strange ♪
♪ I was halfway deranged ♪
♪ Pretty much the same shape I'm in now ♪
♪ And I need you if I'm gonna
make it through this hell ♪
♪ Annabel ♪
(upbeat country music)
♪ Your benevolent way and manner ♪
♪ And my sickly gun shy heart ♪
♪ You wanted for me to heal ♪
♪ But I just tried to conceal
it all right from the start ♪
♪ Keep it honest and open ♪
♪ That's what you always said ♪
♪ Well, what's a man to do
when he don't know the truth ♪
♪ And he lives inside his own head now ♪
♪ Well, I need you if I'm gonna
make it through this hell ♪
♪ Ah ♪
♪ I guess I'll just give it a shot now ♪
♪ Try to make it on my own ♪
♪ God, it just feels like a let down ♪
♪ That this house just ain't our home ♪
♪ It ain't our home ♪
♪ Well, I need you if I'm gonna
make it through this hell ♪
♪ Annabel ♪
(audience cheers and applauds)
- One more time, let's hear it
for 49 Winchester, everybody.
(audience cheers and applauds)
Grab heir album, "Fortune Favors the Bold"
wherever you get your music,
and look out for their
worldwide tour dates
being released soon.